DALE HUMBY: Welcome everyone
to our fourth Hangout
of Experts on Air, hosted by
the Google Developer Expert Team
from around Africa.
To introduce the GDE program,
Google Developer experts
are recognized by Google as
experts on various Google
technologies, such
as Android and cloud.
Every month we host a show,
and it's a live Hangout on air.
And each month we
present a theme.
Today's theme is implementing
material design on Android.
And after the show,
you'll be able to download
the MP3 podcast,
and we'll also make
the video available on
YouTube to watch later.
To introduce our panel
today, we've got Alex Koller.
And he's an Android GDE from
Cape Town in South Africa.
And he's going to be
presenting the Android talk.
We've got Johan du
Troit and Hiren Patel,
and they're both Cloud
GDEs from Cape Town.
We've got Femi Taiwo.
And he's a cloud GDE
from Lagos [INAUDIBLE].
And Kenneth Kinyanjui, a cloud
GDE from Nairobi and Kenya.
We've got Dario Mungoi, and
he's one of our newest GDEs.
And his speciality
is also Android.
And he's joining us from
Maputo, in Mozambique.
Also joining us today
is Eugene Mutai,
an AngularJS GDE from Nairobi.
And from the Google team,
we've got Mercy Orangi,
and she's in charge of the
Google Developer ecosystem.
She's a community manager
in sub-Saharan Africa
with a main focus
on Google Launchpad.
And myself, Dale Humby,
also a Cloud GDE.
I come from Cape Town.
And I'll be hosting
your show today.
First off, we're going to hear
from our spotlight speaker, who
is Femi.
And he's one of our newer
GDEs, telling us about himself
and what's happening in
his community in Nigeria.
Then we're going
to have Alex, who
is going to be presenting
our topic for today,
"Implementing Material
Design on Android."
After which, we go into a five
minute question and answer
session, where you can post your
questions in the Hangout on Air
Q&A app, the G+ event page,
or the Google Development
Africa's community G+ page.
And we'll give Android GDEs
Alex and Dario a chance
to answer your questions.
And then we're going to have
a quick wrap up at the end.
So first up, we've got Femi.
Femi, you're one of our first
Google Developer Experts
in West Africa.
Can you tell us a
bit about your story
and how you got into
being in software?
FEMI TAIWO: Right.
Thanks, Dale.
I'm glad to be here.
My name is Femi Taiwo.
And I'm a developer on
Cloud, the first [INAUDIBLE]
here in West Africa.
I am the CTO for a company that
I co-founded six years ago.
We are called INITS, and
we do solutions mostly
around identity management.
So you asked about my story.
I began programming about 12
years ago with QBasic on 133.
And I have spent
quite a bit of time
moving around five or
six different languages.
I've sort of settled on just
two, that's Python and PHP.
I love [AUDIO OUT]
weekend hacks,
creating small
apps, small stuff.
[INAUDIBLE] still like
writing lots of code.
DALE HUMBY: Cool.
And part of the
work that you do is
to help organize
events around Lagos.
What sort of events are
upcoming that we could go to?
FEMI TAIWO: It's
called a DevFest.
A DevFest brings
together hundreds
of developers in one location
to learn, share, and interact.
Here in Nigeria,
there are six of them.
We've already had three.
And there's one happening now in
Abidjan this weekend, next week
in Kano, and finally, one in
Lagos at the end of November.
You can find out more
about them on the links
we share after this [INAUDIBLE].
DALE HUMBY: Cool, thank you.
And you also have made a
couple of apps in your past.
Anything that you're
famous or infamous for?
FEMI TAIWO: Yes.
Our most popular
gig is software we
wrote that was used
to register 70,
71 million people in Nigeria
for general elections.
Computer software that did that.
And in respect to apps,
it would be NewsBasket.
It's a mobile app focused
on news in Nigeria,
and something that we
just released again today.
DALE HUMBY: And recently
you've migrated NewsBasket
to Material Design, right?
FEMI TAIWO: Yes.
There's now a new version we
put up on Play Store today.
It was created using much
of our design principles.
And the feedback from our first
users has being quite good.
We're happy with it.
[AUDIO OUT] --looks,
it feels, [INAUDIBLE].
DALE HUMBY: Great, thanks Femi.
I'm now going to
hand over to Alex.
And he's going to tell
us how we can migrate
our apps to Material
Design, like Femi
did for his NewsBasket app.
Over to you, Alex.
ALEX KOLLER: Thanks, Dale.
So everyone, I am
Alex, and we're
going to walk through
implementing some Material
Design patterns on Android.
So, just a quick recap of
what Material Design is.
It's a design framework
for implementing
a consistent design
across multiple platforms,
including the web
and native mobile.
It focuses on bold
colors, tangible surfaces,
and meaningful motion.
But we're not going to focus
too much on the theory of it,
because in our previous
episode of this Hangout on Air,
Hiren Patel covered that and
implementing it on the web.
So be sure to check that
out if you are still
interested in Material Design.
We're going to have lots of
XML layouts and code snippets
in the presentation.
But don't worry about getting
all of that detail down.
These slides and
more information
will be available
after the show.
So why go Material?
Well ultimately, it's to improve
the UI and success of your app.
Using a design that's consistent
with the operating system
design builds the user's trust
in your app and your brand.
Case studies suggest that
a well-implemented material
design can significantly
increase conversions
within an app.
Google Developer Story videos
are first hand experiences
of developers using
Google products.
And we're going to
look at a few of those
now, where the teams actually
implemented in Material Design.
Up first is Trello, which
is a visual collaboration
tool that gives teams a shared
perspective on projects.
And they found that after
implementing Material Design,
they saw a significantly
increased engagement
from users across most of
the tasks within the app.
The next one we're going
to have a quick look at
is The Hunt, which is a style
and product sharing community.
They found that in comparison
to platforms where they didn't
have any Material Design,
they saw a 50% improvement
in starting hunts.
And this is a strong
indication that people
want to interact
with Material Design.
The last one we're going
to have a quick look at
is Pocket Casts, which
is a leading podcasting
app on Android.
And they found that
Material Design
helped them make the app
available across all forms
of Android, including Android
Wear, Auto TV, and Chromecast.
And this led to a 30%
increase in sales.
So be sure to watch these
and more Developer Story
videos to learn how those who
have already found success
have done it.
So now that you're convinced
that Material Design is
something you want
to do with your app,
how are we going to
go about doing it?
Well, that's where the Design
Support Library comes in.
It's part of the support
library family on Android.
It adds support for various
Material Design components
and patterns for app
developers to build
upon, such as
navigation drawers,
floating action buttons,
snackbars, and tabs.
It also lets you
apply material styles
to all existing components,
such as EditTexts, CheckBoxes,
and dialogues.
And possibly most
importantly, it
lets you build a
consistent material
design all the way
back to Android 2.1.
So to implement this Design
Support Library in your app,
simply add this dependency
to your gradle build file.
As you can see, I've listed
other support libraries that
are available, and these will
help you create a more complete
material design.
Such things as CardViews
and RecyclerViews.
But we're going to focus
just on the Support Design
Library for now.
So the first thing you'll do is
set up your application theme.
And it's important to note
here that we are extending
the Theme.AppCompat themes.
And that makes sure that
the material attributes
are applied to your app.
And then we'll want to
define a few colours.
Colour Primary, Primary Dark,
and Colour Accent are the main
colours that will be used
throughout your app for styling
and giving colour to
things such as toolbars,
and action buttons, and
accents to all of the controls.
We're going to have a quick
look at how to implement
a few material UI components.
First one we're going
to have a look at
is quite a common
pattern where there
is an AppBar and
flexible space at the top
of some scrollable
content on your screen.
As you can see on this slide,
as the user scrolls up,
the top section gets collapsed
into a more compact version
of that.
So to get started,
the first thing
we need to know a bit about
is the CoordinatorLayout.
And this is a new layout
that was introduced
in the Design Support Library.
And it coordinates
animation behavior
between views inside of it.
It's possible to define
your own behaviors,
but basic ones are provided for
floating action bars, AppBars,
and snackbars.
So basically, it
lets the views inside
of that layout interact
with each other
without those views knowing
too much about the other views.
Let's get into
our AppBar layout.
So this XML layout shows
that we have an AppBar layout
at the top.
And inside of that, a
CollapsingToolbarLayout.
And that's the one that's
responsible for actually
collapsing the space and moving
the views around inside of it.
Now you can see, we've set
some scroll flags on that view.
We've set it to scroll
and exit until collapsed.
And that says that
when the user scrolls,
that section should also scroll.
And it should be collapsed
until the user starts
scrolling back down again.
And inside of that layout we
have two views-- an image view
and a toolbar.
The image view is acting as a
flexible space in this example.
And the toolbar will
be pinned at the top.
And let's set the collapse mode
to pin so it will stay there.
And on the image view,
our collapse mode
is set to parallax.
And that means it will scroll
with a parallax effect,
slightly slower than
the content below it.
And that's all you need
to implement that pattern.
It's quite straightforward.
Next we'll look at the
Floating Action Button.
And just as a reminder,
that's the circular button
that's used to promote a
primary action on your screen.
It's usually anchored
to one of the corners
or sides of the screen or
along the seam of two views.
To implement it is
quite straightforward.
We simply implement a
FloatingActionButton view.
And this extends an image for
you so you can use it in a way
that you're familiar with.
But there are a couple
of attributes that we'll
look at specifically.
And that's the layout gravity,
which lets us anchor that
to the side of our layout.
And also the FAB size.
We have two options there, the
normal size or a mini size.
And as you can see, we've
included this inside
of our CoordinatorLayout
because that lets
us interact with other views.
So we're going to have
a quick look at adding
a snackbar to the set up.
Now the animation
you'll see on this slide
shows that when the
snackbar comes up,
it actually moves the floating
action button with it.
So, snackbar is like a
toast, except it forms
part of the view hierarchy.
So it actually interacts
as part of your view.
And what we've got here,
this little bit of code
is to say when the Floating
Action Button is pressed,
simply create a
snackbar and show it.
And that's what you're
seeing in the animation.
And because those
two views are inside
of the same Coordinator Layout,
they interact with each other.
And that's a Coordinator Layout
in action using the default
behaviors of those two views.
One more pattern is
the Navigation Drawer,
that you should
be familiar with.
It's a flexible
navigation pattern,
and it usually slides
in from the left.
As you can see in
this screenshot,
it has a section at
the top where you can
put anything you want in it.
And then the navigation
items below that.
And we've actually got it
separated with sub-items
in this one.
So let's have a quick look at
how we will implement that.
First, you'll see on the
left we have the XML layout.
At the top level of our layout,
we have the drawer layout.
And inside of it,
as the last child,
we add the new NavigationView.
And that is effectively a
drawer that will slide out.
And we've added special
properties to that.
The Header Layout, which can
be any XML layout that gets
inflated into that properties
section of the page view.
And then we also have
the menu [? attribute. ?]
And that will look
for an XML menu
file that we've defined on
the right of this slide.
And that defines the
groups and items that
are in the navigation drawer.
And you can see that
we've got one group there
and multiple items inside of it.
And for each item, we can define
the icon that's displayed,
and also the title of
the text is displayed.
So with those two files
and the Header Layout,
you can very quickly get a
Navigation Drawer in place.
So if you've been
following along,
you already have a
materialized app.
Isn't that fantastic?
Well, almost.
It's worth noting that although
it's very easy to get started,
there are a few tricky bits you
need to master along the way.
But don't worry,
it's available online
in a detailed codelab, which
we'll look at in a second.
It's also worth
noting that there
are a few bugs in that
Design Support Library,
but there are regular
releases that help fix
those problems as they develop.
So the codelab I
mentioned is a brand
new Material Design and
codelab for building
apps with the Design
Support Library.
Exactly what we've
covered today,
but in a lot more detail.
The link will be posted
just after this Hangout,
but that is definitely
the place you
will want to start if you're
new to Material Design
and want to get going quickly.
So there are no excuses now.
It's time to get going.
And here are some important
links and resources.
First of all,
Material Design Spec.
That's everything you need to
know about Material Design.
And we've also got the code
lab, which I just mentioned.
And probably most importantly,
our Google Developers Africa
community.
It's the best community of the
funnest developers in Africa.
So be sure to check that out
if you're not familiar with it.
Thank you.
DALE HUMBY: Thanks
so much, Alex.
That was great.
I'm now going to hand over
to Johan and Kenneth, who
are going to field the questions
that you may have and post them
to Android GDEs Alex and Dario.
So if you have any questions,
please post them in the Hangout
on Air Q&A app or in the G+
event page for this event,
or on the Google Developer
Community G+ page.
So Johan and
Kenneth, over to you.
Thanks.
Yeah, so we're watching
all the channels.
If you have any questions,
just pop them in there.
So the first one I got was,
"is there any downsides
to actually using Materials?"
So, does it take more battery,
is it a bigger app size?
Is it only for
certain types of apps?
What would you say?
ALEX KOLLER: That's
a great question.
Basically no,
there aren't really
any major drawbacks to
implementing Material Design.
It's really just what
sits on top of your app.
It's the UI layer.
Although it's definitely
not suited to all apps.
I wouldn't use it for
a game, for example.
But for most general
applications,
it certainly is the
design framework
that you should look at.
KENNETH KINYANJUI: We've
also got another one.
Is it only on certain
versions of Android?
And also, "will it be a
problem if my users are running
older versions of Android?"
ALEX KOLLER: Another
great question.
Maybe this is a good opportunity
to bring Dario into the fold.
DARIO MUNGOI: Hello guys.
So going straight to
the answer, actually,
as Alex said during
the presentation,
the Material Design
supports apps
running from API 7, which
is the version 2.1 app.
So there's no need to worry
about compatibility issues.
So it's good to go.
JOHAN DU TOIT: [INAUDIBLE] I've
got another question about when
you're putting screenshots
on the app store
and it's a Material app.
Are there certain guidelines
that you should follow?
Where can you have
a look at those?
ALEX KOLLER: Well,
there isn't really
any difference between
providing screenshots
when your design changes, it
will be done in the same way.
But there are a bunch of
tools available to help
you make better screenshots.
Starting with
Android Marshmallow,
there's a System UI
Tuner developer option,
which lets you set the
status bar as you want it
for your screenshots.
And then also the
Device Art Generator,
which is available online.
It helps you put
your screenshots
in nice, device frameworks,
frames, and nice shadow effects
so you can get very good looking
screenshots quite easily.
JOHAN DU TOIT: And I'm
sure you'll link us, right?
ALEX KOLLER: I
certainly will, yeah.
KENNETH KINYANJUI: So
we've got another one.
"Are only Material apps
featured on the App Store?"
ALEX KOLLER: Aha.
That is a question I've heard
from quite a few developers
because when Material
Design came out,
it was obviously quite a lot
of work to immediately migrate
to Material.
So there was a concern
that their apps might not
be featured by Google.
But Google have said
that they don't only
feature Material apps.
They feature well designed
apps and well built apps.
So you don't have to stick
to Material framework.
You should do what's best for
your product and your app.
JOHAN DU TOIT: I've
got another one.
So the Support
Library, does it only
point to that set of
components you showed,
or is it a certain guideline,
it's principles, concepts,
that you can follow?
ALEX KOLLER: Right.
So I mentioned briefly the
Support Library family.
And that means that there's
actually a whole bunch of
[AUDIO OUT] And most
of them are focused
on features being back ported
from new versions of Android.
But the Design Library
is specific in that it
adds new components and
behaviors to Android.
So the Design Support Library
does add new UI components,
whereas the Material Spec, which
is the online version of how
Material should work--
that explains how
it should work in great detail.
Whereas the Design
Support Library
provides you with components
to just add to your app.
JOHAN DU TOIT: I'll take
the next one then quick too.
I see someone who likes
the YouTube animations.
Are animations-- because
I've seen a lot of them
and this person has to--
when you scroll down
and you see the header grow
smaller, is that built in?
So, are there animation
libraries that you can use?
Or is that separate
from Material?
How would you go
about doing that?
ALEX KOLLER: Excellent.
So one of the important
parts of Material Design
is to use motion meaningfully.
And you described some
good examples of that.
And the Support Design
Library does help facilitate
a lot of that motion, as we saw
with the snackbar on the FAB
and also the collapsing
toolbar layout.
The example about
the icon animating
is probably a brilliant
example of the animated
effect [? drawable. ?]
Now that is available
in Lollipop and Up
only at the moment.
It hasn't yet been back ported
to the Design Support Library.
But I'm pretty sure we will
see it there soon enough.
JOHAN DU TOIT: Awesome.
Well, that's all the
questions I can see.
Kenneth, I don't know
if you can see any?
DALE HUMBY: OK.
Thank you Johan and Kenneth
for fielding all the questions.
Thanks everyone, for who
all asked the questions.
And to Alex and Dario
for a great talk
and answering our questions.
Next, we have Hiren, who's going
to tell us about a recent PHP
conference that he presented at.
Over to you, Hiren.
HIREN PATEL: Thanks, Dale.
So yes, I attended the
PHP conference recently.
And basically, it's a conference
that happens every year here
in South Africa.
And this year it happened
up in Johannesburg,
sort of early October.
So the conference
this year was centered
around one day of workshops
and two days of talks.
And as part of the
GDE program, we
ran a workshop on PHP on Google
App Engine at the conference.
So I thought this was
quite a fitting time
to run the workshop.
The reason being that
PHP on Google App Engine
is now generally
available, which means
it's fully supported and so on.
So that went quite well.
We went through the
intro and a helloworld
on getting PHP
running on App Engine.
We also had some international
speakers talking about PHP
Composer, as well as http/2.
And then we had a passionate
bunch of local speakers
as well.
So if you asked me what were
the hot topics at the conference
this year, they would have to
be the workshop and the talk
on Docker, the talk on
PHP 7, the talk on http/2,
and the workshop
and talk on Laravel,
which is a new upcoming
PHP framework for the web.
And if you asked me
what the community was
most excited about at
this conference-- so
we all know that most of
the web is run with PHP,
and so the community
and the speakers
were mostly excited
about the upcoming PHP 7.
Mostly because of its
performance advantages
over the previous version 5.
So for those who aren't
following the PHP 7
announcements, PHP 7's
is now close to that
of Facebook's HipHop runtime.
So there's quite a bit of
reason for excitement there.
And then couple
this with http/2,
and it means a lot
of good things coming
for the web coming forward.
So there's a lot of excitement
about these two things.
So I just want to
remind the audience
that the talks for the PHP
conferences are all recorded
and will go on to YouTube.
So if you go to YouTube and you
search for the PHP South Africa
user, you will find recordings
for not just this year,
but the previous years
of conference as well.
So if you are a PHP
developer and you
need to keep up to the industry
with what's going on in the PHP
world, I highly encourage you
to check this conference out.
phpsouthafrica.com.
And that's the wrap.
Back to you, Dale.
DALE HUMBY: Thanks
very much, Hiren.
That's our show for the month.
Thanks everyone for listening in
and posting all your questions.
And to Alex and the GDEs
for joining us today.
In the next two days,
we'll be posting
a link to the audio file as well
as a link to the YouTube video.
We'll put those in
the G+ community.
We'd also love your feedback
for the show and any ideas
for the next show.
If you would like to
speak at an upcoming event
or be featured in our spotlight,
also fill in the form.
We'll make the links to those
feedback forms available
in the G+ group.
So, thank you everyone, and
see you in the next month.